when you think of medical technology you
probably don't think of your phone but
these days smartphones like Apple's
iPhone are taking medicine mobile
Apple's App Store has over 150,000
applications apps for short but among
the games calendars and other random
stuff there are also some great medical
apps in fact medical apps is one of the
fastest growing categories in the App
Store with about 2,000 apps already
available there's plenty to learn see
and even do with these apps so whether
you're a patient doctor or researcher
here are 10 great apps to look out for
say your doctor with a patient is
asthmatic she wants to try a new
treatment and you wonder if their
clinical trials nearby she can
participate in solution pull out your
iPhone the clinical trials app can find
nearby trials within seconds you can
even filter based on study type age
group and trial phase give your patient
the info and she's set to go but what if
you want to know more about this new
asthma treatment for example information
on previous studies well tap on over to
pub search plus it's a portable version
of PubMed that shows article PDFs right
on your phone you can even check out
subscription-only content if you have a
subscription of course but what if
you're an asthma researcher not a
physician according to its developer the
asthma md appt can be the future of data
collection the app currently serves as a
mobile diary for asthma sufferers
allowing them to log their symptoms
asthma triggers and medications that
info however will soon be put into a
database and made available to
researchers I'll it an app for diabetes
has similar potential patients can log
things including their glucose levels
and insulin shots the information
according to eyelids developer might
also be used for research so what if
you're one of those drug researchers
you're in the lab and you need to insert
a marker into a gene related to diabetes
you'll probably use a restriction enzyme
and the I cut DNA app can tell you just
which one I
DNA is a mobile database of more than
2,000 restriction enzymes and DNA
sequences if you're in the lab listening
to music on your iPhone you can tap over
to I cut DNA type in the sequence you
want to cut let's say GT and AC and
according to the app you'll need F of 1
looks like we've got a sense of how
these apps can help you in the lab but
what if you're out in the big swine flu
infested world we're all germaphobes at
heart and the health map app can help
inform your paranoia the app takes local
news reports and shows you what to be
careful of uh-oh looks like there's a
mumps outbreak in New York better get a
vaccine which reminds me you might not
remember which vaccinations you got
recently Novartis has released backs
track to help you out you can record
your vaccinations track your next ones
and even find immunization clinics
nearby okay so it might be rare that you
need to know when you received your last
tetanus shot it's also rare that you'll
need to perform CPR but pocket CPR can
show you how the app offers a training
guide helpful for amateurs like me and
you can even test your CPR skills with
it what about a more day-to-day task
like checking someone's heart rate if
you're a doctor unlike me you can use
this digital stethoscope and hook it up
to your iPhone using the stethoscope app
you can see and record heart sounds in
real time here's one last appt your
patients wondering where is the nearest
medical marijuana dispensary yes there's
even an app for that the cannabis app
can tell doctors and their patients
where to go and where it's legal
whether you're in the lab or walking the
streets you never know what kind of
medicine you'll need handy reporting for
Nature Medicine I'm Christian Torres